john kennedy
in a speech in 1963 i believe it was
quoted george bernard shaw the socialist
playwright and he said shaw pointed out
some people see things that are and say
why i dream things that never were and
say why not and he he uttered this line
as they were supposed to be inspiring a
lot of democrat politicians have used it
since
what he doesn't point out is that that
line comes from a play by george bernard
shaw a place cycle called back to
methuselah it's in the character of the
serpent tempting eve in the garden of
eden as satan very famously said this
inspiring line from bielsa bob the devil
himself i
he uses this line but that really is the
agenda right it's to re remake society
we the past is always terrible according
to the progressives the past was awful
we never want to go back there and then
the presence always a crisis and the
future is going to be really really
great just give us more power just give
us more of your rights and and abolish
more of your customs that's what they
tell you never quite works out that way